so welcome everyone
uh i'm gonna talk about using the web
for music production and live
performance
and as you already said i'm jan i'm the
dev tone on twitter and that might be
important
later i'm a front-end developer from
berlin
i'm not i don't have a musical
background but i'm very passionate for
music
i keep saying that but actually it's
wrong
in 2004 i had this band well we had this
website
and we didn't have songs but we were
geeks and we know how to make websites
and we wanted to have an awesome website
we had like an awesome table layout
going on here and uh
we had the best name the hybrid monkeys
apparently we didn't know what png alpha
was if you look at the colors here well
so that's that's my musical background
not not really fancy
um but audio on the web also has like a
dark history
uh if you look for example at bg sound
who who here knows the background sound
yeah we've all been there done that
like you could use it for media in the
background of your page
wow then you had the possibility to do
like
to use flash or java to to replay
songs on your website but it's not it
doesn't really feel nice because it's
not the web
technology like it's all just java and
flash
and then finally we had the audio tag
and all was amazing because we could
stream audio we
could analyze audio and um everything
was good
until the point where we wanted to do
more
than just listening to music because uh
we also want to um
like create filters uh create music and
so
people from mozilla came up with the
audio data api
uh which was which allowed you to create
music
but uh in a not really nice way and the
spec had some flaws so
chris rogers from google came up with
the web audio api
and that's where you are right now it's
an awesome api
and when i looked at this it kind of
looked like
the history of layouting on the web as
well because in the beginning we had
frames which is like
background sound nobody uses it anymore
i hope
i hope and then we advance to table
layout to object embed
so we know table layouts work so this
object
but it's not really the nicest thing to
use
so then we advance to float layouts so
everything was nice but you still had to
use some hacks
like clear fixes
and then we had the audio data available
flexbox version one
which we then dropped and we had flexbox
so that's the history of audio on the
web and so their
web audio api basically gives you a low
level access to all things audio
you can create sounds from scratch
you can manipulate sounds with filters
you can time sounds precisely you don't
have to use set timeout or any of that
it's just very precise and tons of other
cool stuff that i will not mention
like spatial audio like you have like
for 3d games if you need like an audio
source coming from that direction with
that intensity
it's right within you can just use it
so there are many demos with the web
audio api
but i kind of wanted to make like a real
software
with the web audio api and i was still
in uni and so
i had a nice professor and he let me
come up with a nice title for thesis
it's
building a collaborative music
production environment using emerging
web standards
which basically means what i wanted to
do was to create
a music production software that runs in
your browser
and it says collaborative so because i
wanted to make it collaborative because
we're on the web
so we could use web technology to make
like bands
interact if they work remotely and the
first thing i did was uh
because i was in academia i had to
analyze things first
i had to look at the audio editors are
there like because they have years of
development and best practices
and they have common interface patterns
um
i wanted to get like a minimum feature
set because i had six months of time
and i needed to find like what do i need
to do to make people use it
um and so i looked at for example
garageband
you have like uh you have the controls
over here you have like tracks
you have previews of the of the songs
looks kind of easy to use
and then if you look at ableton which is
a more professional software
you can see the same pattern here you
have like some controls over here you
have
the tracks also here and some previews
and
the same image is in all the others as
well like in reason
um so analyzing audio editors you have a
timeline left to right
you have previews and depending on
content they're different if you have
drums
it's not a waveform or if you have like
a recording it's a waveform
you have tracks as rows and what you
need is a way to record stuff
and you need to be able to import stuff
so that's two of the basic features
also you need like a drum machine so
people can come up with
awesome songs and you need a synthesizer
for nice melodies so that's what i
needed to do
and this is how it looks like in the end
so you can see the pattern here you have
like the controls
you have the tracks you have the
previews this is a synthesizer this is a
drum track
but as i said before
there's one more thing because all the
other editors were missing collaboration
and this editor has
collaboration built in and this is what
i want to demo
now okay no
before i want to talk about why do we
need this why do we need collaboration
it's awesome for remote band
brainstorming imagine you're like
in a band with a guy from london and in
berlin and you could just jam
and uh you want to have autosave and all
the backup which is
a big problem as well but there's one
problem
uh it's sadly not offline the thinking
and i'm sorry team hoodie well
offline first so demo time
let's show this so i will just
go into the editor really quickly
open this one open the communications
panel
oh hey guys so i want to introduce you
to
my brother my brother
hey neil say hi i hope you can hear me
do something
yeah perfect
needs is right now in my hometown in the
west of germany
and then you have will my flatmate from
berlin hey will how you doing
say something oh yeah you can't say
anyway do something
so beautiful so um
normally you could see my face here i
don't know what it's not working but
are you guys ready to jam on something
you can't hear the voices because they
have their
instruments plugged in and you will only
hear the instruments so whatever they
say
yeah go for it guys go for it awesome
we'll see you later
so because i will not show you how they
jam this might take some time
i want to show you the editor and
i want to show you that it's really
working so i have the editor here
i have a synthesizer track i have a drum
track and i have
an audio track so a synthesizer if i
double click here
i can edit the synthesizer nodes i can
make them
longer whatever
you have a lot of settings for the
synthesizer here like you can a
synthesizer is made up of
oscillators that create the sound and
you can
define the types of oscillators you have
a lot of settings here
and i will try to play something it's
not really awesome
but just so you have an idea of how this
sounds like
so you have some filters that change the
sound and you have like an oscillator
which is not playing
you know at the moment
yeah so this is the built-in synthesizer
and then we have the the drum machine if
you double click here you can
edit the drum machine here and you can
see the preview is updating here and
here
and you can just i don't know let's
let's just play the drums
um this is um the interface is timed
with set timeout and set interval
and oh is it too loud i'm sorry um
perfect uh but the sound is timed
in the web audio api because if you have
a drummer that is timed
with a set timeout your band is going to
go nowhere
because it will be all the time it will
be like 10 milliseconds off and then it
adds up to the end and then
it would just be horrible so you can do
that in the editor for example
and you can have like different patterns
like this one
that's cool and you can also just
play audio or you can record stuff this
is what i'm doing
now this is done with get user media so
i need to allow
the microphone input
perfect it's working so you can see
there's a signal coming
i just got just i will just gonna say
hello jsconf then i can upload the
recording
i have it then here in the file browser
i would drag it in
and i can arrange it a bit
and then i can just so the play button i
soloed this one because it doesn't
really work together
uh the play button will then trigger the
global playback and it might sound
something like
this hello jscon
yeah that works
okay but this is not showing the
uh collaboration feature so the color
collaboration works like this
come here so i have another instance
here open here and i can just add a new
track the layout is kind of broken now
and i added it here and it's immediately
is here over here and i can edit here
and it will show up here so it's like
hello
jazz conf and then it's there everything
i do
is synced in real time using the
different
differential synchronization algorithm
if you want to know more about it just
ping me afterwards
it's kind of complicated and so
everything will sync
all the time and so that is what uh
my friends or like my my flatmate and my
brother are doing right now and we can
just go back and check how far they are
i hope something that it worked
well no
let me just talk to them
so my brother's gone so it's not working
oh we can't hear him yeah oh he's gone
as well
well let's see let's see if they've
recorded something
oh that's cool so we obviously we agreed
on a song that they're gonna
make and i would just now do what they
would have oh no
something's happening something's i
wanna okay okay
so this is will now editing the stuff
faster will perfect that's easy
um
so this will be the guitar
i guess because i know um
i'll turn it up a bit and then i will
turn the drums down a bit and then just
move it a bit here let's see that works
so maybe you remember the song
awesome awesome they just made that
let's say bye it kind of worked
awesome awesome see you see you later
you you have a beer for free at the
party
oh my brother's coming back too late
perfect
okay so that worked very well so that
was uh the end result of my
thesis and i think you can already kind
of use it
but i also want to talk about live music
performance and
how can you do live music performance in
the web audio api
you can for example use your instrument
like your guitar plug it in use the api
for amplification and for effects we've
seen that yesterday
stuart memo did it in the introduction
on top of that
jan krutish did the live he live coded
the background
track with with his tool live coder but
i want to
focus on uh using midi devices to
control your application so
to for example control my editor um
and i want to introduce you to the band
the glitch mob
um which is one of my most favorite
bands everything that you see
right there is they are an electronic
ban an electronic music band and they
do songs only with midi devices even the
drums that you can see right now
is midi and
it kind of sounds like this
so you can hear like you have some drum
parts you have some vocals that are
being
invoked by a sampler and i thought
i want to do that as well so this setup
looks like this
you have the three guys they have their
drums and they talk
midi to your software so the problem is
neither do i have three
people capable of doing that including
me
nor do i have the midi instruments and
nor do i have the software
well turns out you can do that on your
own as well
so this is one of my most favorite djs
from japan his name is broken haze
he is demoing something on his ipad and
you can see
it's only him performing and
that inspired me a lot it sounds
something like this
and he's doing that alone on stage with
drums and his ipads and it's just
amazing
so i thought if he can do that alone
maybe i can do that
and what i needed for that is the web
media api which is f
really nuan again if we talk about media
it's not shitty
midi background stuff it's the protocol
for digital instruments that send data
to your application but the
media api is in an early stage you have
to set flags and
i think it only works in chrome right
now firefox people
but the awesome thing is oh no
you've seen nothing the awesome thing is
the web media api
is developed in japan and if you know
the japanese culture
they're kind of freaky and i love that
so they really love the web media api
and they do tons of [ __ ] with it
and they even came up with a mascot it's
called mediap
it has two midi outputs here and it has
keys here and it's
all over the world with in the web
that's not enough so they made an
animation
hi media p hi yeah
well so enough about that so i thought
i need to use this and um
so let's talk about js live performances
last year i did a live performance at
uh reject.js i was using the game
controller api
and that was kind of cool as well and
then
if you've been to this year's reject js
you might have seen the
like the world premiere of the
semicolons if not you have to check out
the video later
they were using oh i'm part of the band
we were using the web audio api as well
and
obviously you've seen the introduction
yesterday and that was all done in web
audio and it was
amazing and i hope
that you are ready for another demo
that i will do right now and i need to
plug in my
ipad just bear with me
a bit
oh and i need to put this on
uh scrub needs ah here we go
so i hope this works uh enjoy this
i hope i'm not being sued afterwards
you can dance
true
true
uh that was basically it but wait
oh no
well yeah yeah
so
sorry sorry so um
thanks if you want to check out the
semicolons uh go to the slides
if you want to check out my brother's
band check it check out the link in the
slides and please check out the glitch
mob and broken ace they inspired me a
lot to do this
thank you
you